and I have an exciting addition to these
live streams to this daily homeroom
which is their team member from our
group that partners with schools and
districts and tries to get
communications out to parents and that
is dan dan are you there there's Dan and
he's gonna help us out try to answer our
questions together he's also going to be
looking at the message boards on the
various social media channels that this
is being streamed out to to try to
surface up the the questions that might
be useful for as many people as possible
just to get everyone up to speed on what
this is especially if this is your first
time Khan Academy is a not-for-profit
with a mission of providing a free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere for many years we've been
building resources for students both in
the classroom and outside of the
classroom resources for teachers inside
the classroom for parents so that they
can learn all the core a core most of
their core academic skills from starting
with pre-k with Khan Academy kids going
into elementary level mathematics
English and language arts we just
launched some English language arts
content going into middle school than
high school math science humanities and
even things like free SAT practice that
we've partnered with the College Board
and when the school closure situation
became a reality we realized that we had
our duty to step up even more and so
we've been trying to create more and
more supports for teachers parents and
students to navigate this crisis last
week we released things like daily
schedules for students of different ages
I think about how can you put all of
these resources from Khan Academy and
resources from other players together
into a very coherent schedule that can
be a something that bridges us until
schools reopened we've been doing
webinars with teachers and parents to
get them up and running and we've been
doing this this this livestream which
we're calling a homeroom which is a way
for all of us really to feel connected
and to each other each other's questions
its way for us to get feedback and ideas
from all of you you know we are now with
our three kids
and I told my wife some of the ideas
about we discussed through it when one
of the homeschooling parents told me
that on our homeroom livestream so it's
just a way for all of us to feel
connected in a time of social distancing
a little bit of community interstitial
tissue as people work on their various
their various resources and so with that
I encourage you students parents and
teachers put your questions your
comments your ideas on the message board
below wherever you're seeing this
whether it is on Facebook whether it is
on a YouTube or or Twitter and we dan
and I are going to get to them and try
to answer them I'll start with a few
quick ones see this from Sonia sab will
you be making any more meditation videos
maybe one for parents and for teachers
I need these now more than ever you can
even read the phone book I just well
that's very that's very generous that
you would like me that that you'd be
willing to listen to me read the phone
book I think you would get tired of that
but know that's a good catalyst and I
would love to do that for those of y'all
who don't know I've gotten serious about
meditation over the last couple of years
and you know meditation can evoke
different images and a lot of people's
mind some people view it as a spiritual
thing or a religious thing but you know
here just talking about it in the most
general possible way which is just a
toolkit to help for us to become aware
of our thoughts to helps to our minds
for coping with some of what many of us
are going through right now and you know
the first meditations we put out there's
actually only a few weeks ago what we're
around student meditations for dealing
with things like stress and
procrastination many of you know that
stress anxiety we're already at record
highs for a lot of especially high
school and college students and so
especially when it comes to test taking
and so we wanted to help with that but
this is a great idea so I think we want
to we want to do that let's see we have
we have Leo says the questions in a unit
test or course challenge are they more
difficult than other questions
it's good question leo so today the way
Khan Academy works is when you do an
exercise the exercise might ask you to
do five questions it's actually coming
from a pool of 20 or 30 questions
and so and whether you're doing an
exercise a unit test or quiz it's coming
from various pools of questions when
you're doing unit tests you're doing
multiple skills so let's say a unit test
has 15 questions in order take ten
questions in it it will then be sampling
from a pool of 300 questions so it is
possible that you see questions that you
have seen in the skill focused practice
or the quizzes or if you're taking a
core challenge in the unit task but it's
unlikely in fact it's very unlikely
they're doing a complete repeats and
we've been doing a lot of analytics on
this we think that the unit test and
core challenge are actually very
indicative of where you currently are in
your dream we are exploring things like
making specialized unit tests and course
challenges that can only be accessed in
that way but we're thinking about
whether that will the whether that will
actually be significantly better than
what is there but that's the current
thing that that you have questions from
Dan I think Dan's got some stuff to
share with us I think so um so we have a
great question from Sharla Karimi
apologies if I pronounced the name I
wanted any recommendation on easy
checkbooks I don't have recommendations
on easy chapter books but we have
published resources and our daily
schedules for students so if you go to
you know you could just go to Khan
Academy org there's a link to access the
daily schedules if you're looking for
easy chapter books I'm assuming that
this would be probably for elementary
school age students who you want to get
ramped up reading in chapter books we we
have a link to a reading list from some
experts on this subject for different
grade levels and so I would go to that
schedule click on that reading list on
the part where we talk about reading
practice and then you're gonna see a
list of great great easy chapter books
one thing I read I recently found out
from another parent over the weekend my
wife told me about this is that it
sounds like audible that this is that's
the M part of Amazon that has books on I
guess audio that they've opened up their
kids section for free so I would also
look at the kids section on audible I
think you'll get some really
books that your children can I'll sleep
to or might even be fun to everyone sit
around the couch and listen to it
together so those are my my two starters
to get you started on the chapter books
Sally Sally Sally I would add that the
team is actually putting together a
reading list and hopefully we're hoping
to get that out next week as well it's
broken up by age group and everything so
awesome
yes so you can use those resources we've
linked to obviously audible is audio
versions of it and as Dan just mentioned
we're gonna make even clearer reading
lists by grade level in literally coming
days question Sal from mathematics II
and this is a really important one
why are getting questions wrong so
important so getting questions wrong and
obviously you don't want to get a
question wrong if you can get it right
it's not like that's gonna do any good
but you know a lot of times when you do
anything in life whether it's math or
free-throws or anything when you fail we
oftentimes kind of beat up on ourselves
sometimes get discouraged it hits our
ego a little bit our pride and like
maybe I don't need to do this thing and
you're oftentimes tempted to disengage
and the the thing to remember is that
that's that those times that you're
you've failed
you're kind of discovering your edge and
it's when you operate in your edge that
you're going to grow the most and so
there's even been research studies that
when people fail at something let's say
a cognitive task like a math question
but then they reflect why they failed
why they got it wrong and how they could
have done it differently that's actually
when you formed if those of you familiar
with things like weightlifting
oftentimes you'll hear people say oh you
you should do some reps until failure
failure is a good thing it shows that
you you've had a real workout sometimes
failure has been stigmatized because
you're like oh if I fail a test that's
bad I got an F or if I got a bad grade
or if I get questions on a test and then
it reflects on me and that's why at Khan
Academy you know I just described how
our items are created we want to give
you as many chances as possible
to show that you can become proficient
in a concept and so it's not that when
you do it once you got 80% you got 20%
wrong all of a sudden you're just
labeled 80% student forever you can keep
going at it like this idea generally
speaking is called mastery learning it
predates Khan Academy many efficacy
studies showing that it can accelerate
folks learning it was just hard to
implement historically if you didn't
have some tools that can have almost an
infinite number of questions give you
immediate feedback and have and be able
to personalize to individual students
pace but that's why failure when you
fail on a question that you can kind of
engage in that's you should reflect
that's what your brain might be going
the most and you just have to reflect on
why you got it wrong and then you're
gonna you're gonna get your growth will
only accelerate Daan more questions
questions yep we have a question from
Rebecca doula who asks will there be
more classes using Disney and Pixar
resources there they're one of the more
popular ones on our site yeah so for
those of you who aren't aware of what
Rebecca is referring to we've had a
partnership with Disney Pixar I think we
launched it about five or six years ago
where the the Pixar team in particular
said hey would it be cool if we could
help expose students to have math
storytelling and other things are part
of the movie creating process and so we
have this thing on Khan Academy called
Pixar and box and you could view it as
an enrichment but you can see how coding
how math how writing are essential for
creating some of the movies that we all
know and love today
Rebecca answer your question so we have
picture NEBOSH we don't have any plans
right now for any any new content like
that but definitely keep us posted what
are the things you like about Pixar in
the box what are the things you want
more of and obviously we can always
consider consider possibilities so we
have a question it's pretty relevant
with school closures happening all over
the world TJ can we be asked well Khan
Academy try to accommodate other
countries different subjects so a great
question TJ the simple answer is - yes
to certain degree I just had a
interaction with our team in India we
we have a decent-sized team by our
standards about 14 people in India and
and I was asking them how they're
responding to the school closures there
and they've been doing very similar
things to what we've been doing in the
u.s. publishing schedules being able to
do more supports for teachers parents
and students and so those are obviously
linked in to Khan Academy India there's
also a fully Spanish version of Khan
Academy
yes khanacademy.org that is used in much
of the spanish-speaking world I think
this is a good push and you know
everything is so fluent for all I know
the team might have already done it but
a lot of the resources we have in
English we want to make sure that
they're going to be available - as well
so that will serve a lot of the
spanish-speaking world same in Brazilian
Portuguese we have a lot of usage in
Brazil and we have 40 informal
translation projects around the world in
other languages and so I look forward to
coordinating with all of these what we
call our language advocates and see how
we can get similar resources in those
geographies they're going to be you know
in certain languages we only have things
like math localize and other geographies
like in you know Spanish speaking Latin
America we have much much more localized
but that's that's a really good push -
DJ yeah I would add that our content in
Brazil is also standards online it's
aligned to the BMCC standards so we're
covered not just in the u.s. so now we
have a great question from yenbo who
asked this is gonna be a question that
pops up frequently how can I not be
distracted what's the optimal amount of
time to study for a given subject that's
a good question and I'm always asking it
myself you know there's an interesting
we had a researcher we published the
video that came to our office about a
year and a half ago and she's pioneered
something called the witch or she she
she spreads word about what's called the
Pomodoro Technique it's called that
because it's based on the it was started
by someone using a timer than the shape
of a Pomodoro tomato and the Pomodoro
Technique is is give yourself a fixed
amount of time let's call it 20 minutes
is what a lot of people talk about and
you learn at a time or obviously doesn't
have
be a timer in the shape of a Pomodoro
tomato but a timer could do it on your
photo and you could do it on a computer
for 20 minutes it's okay for this 20
minutes I'm going to do focused work on
on whatever I need to work on and then
after you're done set the timer again
for 10 or 15 minutes to give yourself a
break and actually force the break
sometimes after 20 minutes you feel like
oh I could keep going I mean the I'm in
the zone so to speak and obviously if
you're really in the zone you don't need
to stop but by knowing that you have
that break it actually makes 20 minutes
a lot more focused and a lot more
productive I know sometimes when I have
large blocks of time and it's
unstructured I kind of can easily
procrastinate find things to delay with
but then all of a sudden if I say oh
wait wait I have a meeting in 30 minutes
let me finish this right before you get
then I can be very focused and so that's
kind of in line with the Pomodoro
Technique I think on top of that that
you know especially with things like
school closures and social distancing
the more that you can find a dedicated
part of you know a desk that you
associate with doing work you only who
work there ideally if you have enough
space it's quiet
etcetera that that would be a great
addition as well but I think it's you
know make a list of the things you need
to do have a schedule we've obviously
published some schedules adapted them to
your needs and then set at that time and
say okay this is my moment I'm gonna do
this when you do it
have you a create a little checklist
there's a little dopamine hit with the
you know neuro neurotransmitter that
makes you happy when you when you get
that sense of accomplishment then give
yourself that break that's important and
it's especially in times with social
distancing try to get a little physical
exercise if you can go outside go
outside go for your walk with the social
distance norms so that and then when you
come back you'll be that much more
energized to have another 20 minute
session so we have a math and science
teacher Samir to jar and he asked how
can Khan Academy be helpful to me as I
teach my students well that's that's a
big question severe you know if we were
talking pre kovat 19 and what I'm saying
is still true with Cova 19 and and
hopefully post kovat 19 our whole focus
was to support teachers like you and you
know every teacher we talked to talks
about the scenario that they get
students at a certain grade level every
student has different gaps some of them
are ready for the material some of them
have need to remediate some concepts
from before grade level some of them are
ready to move ahead and if you're just
one teacher in a classroom of 25 30 35
students it's very hard to address the
particular needs of each of them you
know in ed school it's taught that you
know differentiation is a great practice
but in practice it's actually very hard
to do it when you don't have proper
supports and so a Khan Academy one of
our propositions or values to teachers
are that we want to be that teaching
assistant for you we want to help you
differentiate and so the way this has
worked in classrooms is that for 20% of
class time at least and we see a lot of
good efficacy studies around it teachers
have students working out their own time
and pace on Khan Academy and as they do
so teachers get data on what kids are
working on what are they mastered what
are they not who's engaged who's not and
then that is actionable data that
teachers can use to break students out
into more focused groups if they see a
bunch of students having trouble of
negative numbers okay let me take those
five aside the other can continue to
continue to work then they go back in
and continue working at our own pace let
me not work with the kids who are having
trouble with decimals so that is the
framework that we think can work very
well in math and science class if you're
serving a group of students who have
significant gaps many of them are behind
grade level I've been talking about Tim
Vandenberg Oh Tim Vandenberg a lot who
is an amazing teacher in history in
California and 90% of his students show
up in his classroom below grade level he
actually does two things he
simultaneously works with the students
to learn their own time and pace at the
grade level unit and at the same time he
tells all of his students these are
sixth grade students to start as early
as early learning and a third grade math
and arithmetic on Khan Academy and do
that at their own time and pace as well
so that they can fill in all of these
swiss-cheese gaps that might have
accumulated over time in this kovat 19
world everything i just described is
still operable and the schedules we've
published talk about how it could work
first
of different age groups as there now
were not being able to work from school
and as a teacher I think one of the
powers is you can continue to monitor
that data from your home see what the
students are working on where they're
strong where they're not what they need
to help in and you see that Wow I still
have five or six of my kids who are
really struggling with this concept then
you could schedule a video conference
with them you could say hey why doesn't
everyone come on you know if you're
using a some kind of a learning
management system say Google classroom
you could say hey here's the link to
zoom for you five I'm gonna sign this to
you five students please join me at 2:00
p.m. Eastern Time I'm making things up -
we're gonna do a focus session on
negative numbers because I'm assuming
you've already used you know you've
looked at the hints on Khan Academy
we've looked at the videos and you're
still having trouble I want to work with
you and then you could schedule another
for other kids and then maybe you could
have whole class videoconferencing to
say okay let's see how everyone's
working what can I do get feedback from
students to unblock them more so I think
that whole world of things are things
that could could be very powerful in
this now distributed remote world that
we we find ourselves in other questions
yeah we have a question we have a
question from Galen McCann who is
actually one that I want to know - do
you have all the black hole badges how
how much people are in the black hole
badges so simple answer is for those who
don't know what a black hole badges or
don't even know about badging we have
badges on Khan Academy and Whitford
various accomplishments and the highest
badge is the black hole badge and we
always wanted to make that for you know
really exceptional things now one of the
things that happened this was about
seven or eight years ago at Khan Academy
I would go and answer people's questions
when they asked them in our in our in
our discussion boards and people didn't
believe it was me and so it's some way
to give evidence to people that that
account was actually my account and so
what we did is we gave me a black hole
badge called the this is Sal black hole
badge and I think then the engineer who
did that he
was trying to you know maybe butter me
up and he gave me a couple more black
hole badges and so I am one of the few
people who has a black hole badge I
believe there others and there's
different times in history different
ways to address it but given how many
questions I get about black hole badges
from students I do think all of us at
Khan Academy have a duty to be clearer
about what it takes to achieve one and
how you can get there cuz it seems like
that is motivating for a lot of folks
great thanks so we have a question from
another teacher Charlene zeus my
students us our students at Khan Academy
map use Khan Academy mappers for math
love it is there a plan for Khan Academy
to do this with reading
that's great question so for those who
don't know what that is there's
something called the map growth
assessment that's taking about 20% of
grades 3 through 8 students in the
United States and it measures student
growth which is a really powerful thing
in fact most of the efficacy studies
that we used to measure Khan Academy's
efficacy we use the map growth
assessment they're run by this nonprofit
called the NW EA and they really are the
gold standard in growth and so the the
mappers was actually a very simple it
was actually a hackathon project from
some of our team members a couple years
ago to be able to say hey if a student
is scoring in this range on the map what
might be appropriate for them to work on
Khan Academy done since then is we've
actually reached out to the nwea and we
formed a partnership with them and what
we're role which is a more ship where
it's actually integrated with the map
assessment and that's something that
we're doing with districts and so for
any of you teachers out there and what
happens is the students take the map
assessment and that automatically pop
populates personalized learning plans on
Khan Academy we call it the map
accelerator on Khan Academy teachers can
adjust it we really pride ourselves and
our ability to give teachers agency
because they know the students best and
then students can work at their own time
and pace and then when they take the
next map assessment the growth that's
measured we can then start to see
hopefully associate
patience between the time on Khan
Academy and the growth on the map so the
map ax replacement on Khan Academy for
personalization and then that work on
Khan Academy we can see how much it
drives a student growth and so that is
something this is a new muscle we're
building for Connick and we're doing it
officially with districts so if that's
something of interest to folks I
encourage you to talk to your your your
school principal the district
superintendent and say hey we should
think about doing this nap accelerator
and the reason why it's a district thing
is you know there's technical things
like rostering and making sure that the
student IDs all work throughout the
district so that it syncs well with
things like the map assessment the
question is are we going to go into
English and language arts so the simple
answer is we don't have plans on mappers
to do that but map accelerator we do
have plans and I hope that that will be
available in the next several years to
answer your question other questions so
Sal we have one more question before we
have to close out today so this one's
from Lukas Mulder up what do you think
Khan Academy's biggest weakness is right
now our biggest weakness so I'm very
aware I could go through a huge list I
think there's a couple we definitely
have gaps in certain subjects and grades
you know people on this you know I've
talked about we have kind of chemically
kids which is reading writing social
learning and math then you know math the
core of math we have from pre-k all the
way through calculus and statistics
English language arts is a new muscle
that we are building and there's only
certain aspects of it that we can tackle
with the modalities that we have on Khan
Academy so we have what's called a beta
version which is like a almost a
pre-release version of our English
language arts
it has reading comprehension pass
passages students can answer questions
but it still doesn't have all of the
mastery mechanics yet obviously we
haven't figured out ways to give
students writing practices per se at
those grade levels so that's a gap I
think we need to figure out you know
middle school science we have a gap
there I've recommended that a lot
well stews can work on high school
biology right now because it's very
relevant to the world and I think they
have the background to do it to start
learning about viruses and RNA and DNA
and I think you know in high school we
actually have many more subjects math
science and humanities I think we
there's more to add
I think another gap that you know I
think is super important is we are we
are building tools that students can
learn at their own time and pace we can
give data to students to parents and
teachers but we don't view that as a
substance a substitute for the live
in-person interaction as you heard from
the the previous teachers questions
Samir's question the ideal is that this
is used in conjunction with a live
teacher or parent where if a student is
stuck they can get motivated to keep
engaging power through those failures
which are really powerful learning
experiences they can teachers can break
take them into breakout sessions and we
were seeing a lot of success with that
in physical classrooms that were doing
you know what you could call blended
environments where kids on working on
Khan Academy and they're able to get
either peer to peer help or help from
their teachers I think in this time of
school shutdowns and the co fit 19
situation I think that in-person
interaction is even more important
because we're all socially distant but
obviously we can't in the same room
together and so that's why in our
calendar and all this live stream I'm
saying it'd be amazing if teachers and
parents and students could create video
conferencing sessions in parallel to the
Khan Academy sessions to be able to do
some of that live in-person interaction
so I think that's a weakness for Khan
Academy I think it can be complemented
with with other things I think there's
many other weaknesses I could get into
the detail of the product you know our
team here we have a big list of stuff
that we hope to tackle over the next few
years and actually that's a good segue
for me to just kind of close out you
know and my closeout first of all thanks
everyone for joining as I said in all of
our live streams I think this is learn
how the the sixth seventh one that we've
been doing I hope you're finding this
useful I actually find this incredibly
satisfying to stay connected with folks
in a world where we are socially distant
and if this can help people feel more
connected that's that's a huge huge
thing and we are doing everything on our
side it's possible to be able to step up
to this crisis we're seeing our server
kappa has gone up more than 2x so things
like our costs are going up and I just
want to remind everyone we are
not-for-profit organization we are
funded through philanthropic donations
you know maybe the gaps the weaknesses
we just talked about on Khan Academy
these are things we would love to fill
but we need resources to do it we need
donations from folks across the board to
make this a possibility you know we've
we've gotten incredible support from
some corporate partners if any of you
are parents working distributed try to
get your corporations involved with us
folks
you know Bank of America was the first
to step up last weekend followed closely
by 18t google.org and then most recently
well I'll announce it tomorrow I'm not
sure if it's public yet but that's just
kind of a that's helping a lot and we
need more corporations but our costs
you know our servers were millions of
dollars before the crisis and now
they're going to be double that you know
in the order of it was six million
dollars a year on just server costs
alone much less we have a team of two
hundred folks who are helping develop
the content writing the software
partnering with school districts cetera
so our costs are going up in this crisis
and we need your help we're running at a
significant deficit that we we're not
sure how long we can do it so anyway
thank thanks everyone for being a part
of this
I will also close out with you know stay
safe stay socially distanced I'm gonna
work on those meditation videos cuz I
think the most important thing is take
care of yourself right now and then
that's going to put you in a position
where you can start thinking about how
you can take care of others thank you so
much thanks for joining
you
you